Let's
[Music]
work with the the pull. Okay. So, you're
you're you're trying to pull away. Okay.
Yeah.
Okay. Don't go flying unless you have
to.
That would be a have to, right? Okay.
So in other words, project I don't want
you
to do that.
You just you you don't have to
necessarily resist so much, but you're
you're not going to move. I'm going to
move you. Okay. Yeah. And that's all.
See, you can stop moving. Do you see
that?
>> So, that's what I want today. Okay.
Boom. And I keep moving you.
You can uh Yep. Stop. Yep. Stop. Okay.
And you could pull again if you want.
Okay. And I use the pull.
Yep. You can always every time you can
pull against it and I work with the
pull.
>> Good. Yep.
>> Do you understand the little rules of
the game?
>> Yes. So I will always move you and then
you can stop and then start to pull
again. Yes. Exactly. Okay.
Pull again if you want. Yep. Every time.
Do it again.
Yep.
Good.
Good. Okay.
Okay, try
So the UK can grab if the UK wants to
grab and pull.
All right. So, let's uh look at
something. Okay. So, uh look at my
hands, Virginia. Okay. her. Not I'm not
trying to get trying to advance. Okay.
All right.
So, I stick. Got it. She's trying to
pull. She's trying to not fall. So, now
when you go, if I just keep pulling, she
should be able to keep stepping. Do you
see? She'll just keep stepping.
So, once you get her there, then that
foot has to be pinned. Do you feel that?
You see? So try try try to step on that
foot.
>> Do you see? Yes.
>> Okay. It's not that she stops. She takes
her step then she stops stepping and now
she pivots on that foot. She she uh
boom. That foot is now pinned.
And then I can use that. Okay. So first
thing, touch wherever. Touch wherever to
get that going. There's that foot pin
right there. Don't fall yet. Okay. Stay
in the fight. And then the third thing
is as she's trying to pull, right? Don't
pull against it. Just like if she's
trying to push, turn the pull. So she
tries to pull, turn the pull. Okay.
So here, there's that foot. So that's
the foot I use. They were pinned. Okay.
Now I turn.
>> Okay. Try it.
[Music]
Pin the foot. Good. Don't give up. So
easy.
Pull. Pull. Try to put your foot back
down. Yes.
Yes. Yes.
Turn it. Yes.
Let go of the hooks.
Turn it. Start.
And I'd like you to challenge her a
little bit more by putting your foot
back down. If you could put it down.
[Music]
Watch all the finger hooks.
>> Did you say can grab or
>> UK can grab if it's going to not be to
your advantage, but you can if you feel
you're losing advantage, you can grab
and pull.
>> Yeah.
You can always grab and pull. Uh you can
do it.
I just don't want the nugget to
again. Put your foot down if you can.
Yes.
So what I what I me I'm the uk. Okay. So
I she she's going to stick to me. I'm
the uk.
Okay. See I can go like this.
>> Okay.
>> Wait. If you do that on me, you're going
to get even more stuff.
>> Okay. So then I wouldn't do
Then I wouldn't do it on me, but I might
do it on her. Okay.
>> Yeah. I want I want the UK at the
F with the Yeah.
So, she is turning, but she's not
spinning.
You need the spiral rotation, not just
rotating.
And it doesn't always have to be a
throw.
>> That was just the one you were going
for. That's the one I corrected.
You got to pin that foot
otherwise they'll keep stepping.
Okay.
So, uh
she she uh uh pushes.
You see
>> she pulls.
If she pushes, I'm not going here. If
she pulls, I'm not going here. Do you
see that? I just trading which foot
the ground the energy is going to. So
when she pulls, it goes to the front
foot. When she pushes, goes to the back
foot. Do you see that? So not not my
line of gravity for pull. She pulls.
It's in the back. When she pushes, it's
in the front. I'm not doing that. Just
shifting. Okay. Just shifting. Just
shifting where I'm at. And I go
front foot. Not here. Front foot.
Back foot.
Okay. Try it again.
There's the turn. Keep it going. Don't
let it Don't change it. Good.
So it's front foot, front foot
start. If it's already hard there, then
you start turning it there.
You looks like you're going to have that
foot. So don't give it up. You gave it
up. Keep the pin.
She can try to put the foot down. Yep.
Do you have to turn it again?
>> You be on the other foot.
>> Okay. So, uh, think about it.
Okay. So, you're you're pulling. You see
the stalemate?
>> Like it were here. I start turning it.
Hi.
>> Do you see? Hi.
>> Okay. And then I try to pin it. Hi.
>> Okay. And if I pin that foot
just like I can make you pick up the
back foot. Do you see?
>> But you'll be able to put the back foot
down and then change the pin on the
front foot. If I There's the pin on the
front foot.
>> Right.
>> Put the back foot down and move the
front foot now. Do you see that?
>> Okay. So that's just cuz you stayed on
that pin.
>> So as you go to move, I keep doing it.
>> Do you understand? And then it's easier.
So, uh, start turning it. There's the
pin on that foot. Do you get it?
>> You're pulling right home. There's the
turn. And right when you go there, I
take advantage of that. Okay. As opposed
to let you get that. So, when you go,
I could do it here or I could do it
here.
>> When you go one foot, okay? But you have
to stay in it. Okay.
See like that. In between that step is
where you can do it.
>> Otherwise, they'll just keep doing that
all day.
Don't fight her grip. Use her grip.
You have to always have one ground
vectoring foot.
Switch roles.
Turn it. Turn it. Yes.
Good. And you're going to not take these
dice. So, it might not be such a pretty
roll.
>> Okay.
>> Turn it.
Well, don't pick it up. Use the
adhesion.
Turn it.
Turn. Turn.
So it's in your head. You're you're
going here. Okay. So right when here
look I turn. Okay. So you you you to
turn one part has to either not move and
the other part has to move or one part
can move slower than the other part
moving faster than you'll turn. Do you
see that? I move both parts together.
It's not going to happen. Okay. If I go
here for because you can keep resisting
this technique, we just are changing the
relationship. That's all we're doing.
Okay. So to get the spiral rotate at the
beginning, one side either stops, the
other side turns there. There's the
turn. Do you see? Okay. And now you work
with whatever they're doing on you.
Okay. So we're back where we started.
Right?
>> Right. Did you see that? So I go one
boom. And as you do that, I take you
further in. Do you see? Okay.
>> And then now, this is what always
happens is as you try to not fall, you
now stopped pulling and you're now
pushing on me. Do do you see that? And
so that's what I use.
>> Okay? But you have to be sensitive to
it.
>> So one side moves the the other one
moves at a different rate. Do you see?
Okay. Okay. And we going. There's that
step.
And you go.
Boom. There it is.
Good. Let you have it if you come up.
Good. Cool. Go in this way. So, you see
that one?
Go back here or over here. No, you were
there and you felt that one coming,
right?
>> So, you pushed and I go here and we're
over here now. See?
And then you felt you push on me.
Boom.
There it is.
Then if they hyper yin yield, you'll
take the spine line. Do you understand?
Okay. So, we're coming in here,
right? And then you go in this way and
disarm yield.
>> Do you see? So, then you take the spine
line.
Okay.
You have to feel all that. So, boom.
Can step if you want. Change it. Pin the
foot to it's too low for you to do
anything with the stepping. You can do
that.
Boom.
There you are. Pushing.
>> You see
there's the yin yield. There's the head.
Okay.
So, right that it's just like an attack.
If I push, you turn it.
>> So, I pull. Yes.
Yes.
So go back when I pushed cuz you had my
balance. That's when you yielded. Good.
Turn it.
Yes.
Lower it. So stick. Stick. And if you go
here, you'll lower it. Good. And then
I'm pushing. And you push.
You have to resist the urge to push back
on me.
Turn it. You can always step if you
don't like it.
Good. There's the push.
Well, that set us back up. Do you see?
You always have to spiral rotate.
So, think of it. You're resisting that.
Do you see that?
>> Can Can you go somewhere where you're
not pulling back on it?
[Laughter]
>> This is what you feel like.
>> I'm just pulling.
>> Yeah. It is pulling on you. So what you
watch watch what I do. Look how you're
pulling there. Got it?
>> Okay. So go back
as you go there. I go here.
>> You see?
So just enough of a change.
That's not what you wanted. You wanted
that.
>> All right.
>> So as you go to pull this goes there.
Then we're changing.
So I go to pull
outward spiral. There it is. And here it
is right here. Do you see
>> height?
>> See the turn
>> height.
>> Okay.
So don't try to overpower it.
>> Turn around it. Do you understand
>> height?
You know my balance is back.
There's the push.
Then you yield spine
back to the limb. Head,
limb,
head and limb.
feel that difference.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
So, go a little slower.
Here's that pull.
Good. Don't push down. See, you smell
leverage. You understand?
>> Cuz you feel your skeletal alignment.
Hi.
>> So, you want to drive on it.
>> You want to drive on it.
>> I should drive on it.
>> You want to I want you to do what you
wanted to do.
>> There's your power. You see?
>> Yes.
>> The only problem is go drive on it. Is
that I can rebound and ground. So, it's
not there.
It's not there.
So here out and you smell this. Do you
see that?
>> Go boom. I'm not going to do that. I
just using it. Using it.
Turn it
in. Yield head.
So try to grab my head. So So you
understand? Grab my head. I'm the uk
see.
Try to grab my head.
Did you feel the yield before it? That's
what you're do cuz you're trying to get
out of it. Don't go out of the the
frying pan into the fire.
Okay. Now, don't smell that.
>> Just use it to pin the foot. You got it.
No, it's pinned.
It's pinned.
>> Right. In the instant you push, it got
pinned.
>> So, in the instant you pin it, turn it.
Turn it here. Don't turn here. Pin.
Turn. Yes. You got it.
>> Go back and don't expect that to fall.
>> So guys pulling pin the foot. Good.
That's it. Okay. Now see what they do.
Trying to get his balance this way. Do
you see?
Good. Push again. Don't. No. Too far.
All you need is the pin.
>> Right.
>> Boom. He moved. He's going to do it
again. You got to get it before he does
it.
>> So, let me show you. Okay, there's the
pin. There's the push.
Pin push. Got it. I go in this way. I
don't go here. It's just pin push.
You got to carefully not to yin yield.
Good. Good.
Oh.
That's it. That's all I need right
there. Right turn. That's it. Yin yield.
Your yin yield is the same desire to
fight. You're trying to win too much.
Yes.
>> Okay.
Go.
There's the desire.
You're fighting.
You're pushing.
You never had it.
Let's stop making a contest. Okay. So,
we'll just do drills. Okay. Uh
pull. Okay. Got it.
Shift this foot.
Pressure on the foot.
>> That foot. We'll go again.
You're doing that
with you.
I'm going to turn.
That was it. Okay.
Ready?
Turn. Don't cut. Just rest. Just rest.
Just rest. That was it.
Don't push down.
You okay?
Pay attention which way my hand is
going.
Watch. Is it going
west or east?
>> East.
>> Change.
Which way is your hand going?
You don't want to come this way. Come
this way. Yes, that was it.
Yes.
Find my foot as light as possible.
Little too light. Too light.
Too light. F. Connect my foot. So,
here's what I mean. Okay. So, uh, as
you're going in, uh, stay where you are.
Okay. This is where I'm pushing here. Do
you see? Okay. But not here.
>> But not here either. Okay. It's in the
center. So I can have the center. So we
have to feel my center.
Center. Find my There it is. Okay. And
do it again.
Good.
You're kind of going that way. Go into
the center. Yes. And it's not about it's
it's about energy, not anatomy.
Okay. Stay there. Can you move me to
your right? Then get enough connection
there. It's not about down. It's in.
There you go. Okay.
Find my center
and go ahead and move it.
Stay. Stay. Not anatomy. You don't You
don't need to get over here to move it.
It's It's enough here. Move it. Yes.
Good.
Now you get there. Move it. Move it.
You want to do anatomy. You want to go
like this.
This
You can always use your other hand.
Okay. If if you know if it's like it's
too slippery cuz we're sweating or
whatever. Okay. Or you double your
friction. But don't don't now go here
and then try to do that. Okay.
Connection. See how you're on the
outside
on top. Good.
Wait for the queue.
More here. Less around me.
>> Sure. Use it.
Don't fight it.
Yep.
Okay, try it.
You're just pulling back.
turn it instead of pulling against it.
Turn. And when we say turn, we always
mean their center.
Their center spiral rotates through
space
and they can't move at the same time
because then we're just rotating, not
spiral rotating.
You have a yin hand and a yang hand at
all times.
And the more they're yin to the yang or
vice versa, the more you'll spiral
rotate.
Do you understand that, Virgin?
Okay.
So that means if one hand's going up and
out
and forward then the other hand is going
down and in and rearward. That's what I
mean. Okay.
So if we had a glass table, both your
hands would be on it, your arms. So we
don't have a up and a down. So we don't
really have a yin and a yong.
You're back on the glass table.
So here's uh it's classic coke hole
in this point. Okay. So, uh, you have a
lot of this
>> and then this hand is doing this. Do you
get it?
>> And so, if we had a glass table, they're
not This might be like a few inches off.
Do you see that? So, it looks like you
want this hand to go up
>> and in.
>> Okay.
>> And towards
>> Do you see?
>> Okay. Well, then this hand will go out
>> down, do you see? And towards me,
>> and then you get the bigger effect on
you.
bigger effect on you because more of the
universe is working upon you and not
just aspect of it. Okay. All right. So
that's what I mean. Okay.
>> And we're usually not able to do it
because we get stuck on one point.
So that you stay where you are please.
Your right hand is all you're going to
get out of that and it is enough if you
take it to its final point.
>> There it is. Now with the other hand go
more in and up and push. And that will
be a pivot point. Do you see?
Fulfill more.
Ground the front foot.
Change levels. Change levels.
Now leave that where it is and go
forward into her center, not around her
center.
There you go. If that's what it looks
like you're trying for that, that's how
you would do that.
Change heights.
Change heights. Change heights.
So when I think spiral rotate, I think
like a orbitron on a corkcrew roller
coaster.
You remember what a Obitron was? Was a
carnival ride. You sit in the middle of
it and it goes all 360. Okay. Now
imagine one of those on a corkcrew
roller coaster.
>> Okay. That's what I mean by spiral
rotate.
So my hands have to do different things.
Never lose the front foot if that's the
one that's grounding.
What one feels y don't push through. Go
to the other hand. It's the universe. So
if one hand feels yang and you had a yin
and a yang hand, the other hand has
room. Okay. So, you go to the other
hand,
change levels.
Okay. So, the right probably feels yang.
So, the left is going to be in a yin
phase. Has more yang potential. You go
to it
and never predict.
>> So, feels tight. So then the other one
comes around.
Yes. Do you do you do you get what I'm
saying for real?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So because it because it's a
cosmogonic truth. Okay. That if I get
these things going, do you get it? So
let's push push really hard on this
hand. Do you see that? Well, this one is
now in a yin phase.
I I don't know why and I don't care why.
Okay. So, the other we do the other one.
We'll get there again. Okay. And now
lift up really high on that hand. And
your instinct is to shove down here. But
now this one goes in. Do you get it? So
you already know that. So when you feel
the the force in your own body
stop and you go to the other hand, it
will be in the yin phase. Okay.
>> Okay. If you can't feel it, you should
be able to feel it, but if you can't
feel it, you can cosmogonically
map it. It's going to be open.
>> Okay. It's like a app that tells you
that Starbucks is open. Okay.
>> On your road trips. Yes.
>> Then you did not generate a yin and a
yang hand. You did not spiral rotate the
fight.
>> Okay. Yeah. So, first do that
and take one take them both as far as
they can go and one will go further.
See how your hands are in that same
level.
So, here's here's what I mean. Uh, you
get stuck on
that she's she's pulling you. Do you get
that? And you try to do something on one
hand, but now that you left that hand
dead. Do do you you're being
cosmogonically mapped. So as you did
something with one hand, that hand went
yong and this hand went yin.
So you didn't do anything with it.
>> So as she goes to pull in, you're always
doing something with the two hands
together. Always doing something.
>> Don't get f focused. Usually what
happens is she pulls and you feel one of
them's taking your balance more than the
other one. So that's the one that you
focus on. And this hand went dead. So
she's going. You can see how this
elbow's anchored more. Do you see that?
So I feel my b I feel my line of gravity
being taken that way. Okay. So again,
that's only a problem if you're not
grounding because if you are grounding,
go ahead. My line of gravity never
moves. Okay. But if should that happen,
then you this is where your attention
goes. You'll feel that it's very yin.
It's like her she didn't even have
anything on the other hand because she
was being cosmogonically mapped and she
overemphasized one hand gave me the
other hand. Okay. But if you're
grounding it's a moot point. Okay.
You could do it any old way is what I
mean. You could done either side.
See, our hands are on the table.
don't come off the ground vector of the
front foot.
And then each hand follows that yinyang
rule. So you you I did go to the other
hand if I felt this hand is at max yong
now I would be yong yong clashing. Okay
max yong is their yong value. Okay so if
you push past it that's a yong clash.
Okay. So, what I first explained was I
if you get at that max yong on that
contact point, I should have said that
the other hand will be in a yin phase.
But at each hand, it's that contact
point that is at max yong, not the next
contact point on that hand.
Okay? So, because you you got there, so
we'll use you again. Okay? So you're
you're uh going here and that's where
you felt that. Do you see that?
>> It's it's this relationship that's in
the yong face. Do you got it?
>> So she as she's here when I go here, do
you see
>> it's not in the young face?
>> So come back.
So come back and you'll see what I did.
>> It's you lifting up
>> and me pushing down. That's the yong
face. Do you see that?
>> Then you can leave that where it is. And
this hound will have yin space. Okay?
>> Or you can change this hound. And I did
and I went this way.
>> And you'll find more yin space. Okay?
That's what I mean. Okay? You don't have
to. And you shouldn't be trapped in that
yang phase. We because the trapping is
the bad part. Not not that it was at a
yang phase and then you went yin on the
other hand. It's I can tell your mind is
just stuck on it. That's the bad part.
Okay, try it again.
Distinct yinyong.
So, right there on your right hand, if
you just point, stop trying to touch her
and point your fingers more down
straight. Yeah. Do you see? You'll have
more room. Okay,
>> you can do it here again. Point them
down. Just down. Just down. Just point
down until that runs out.
and you know if it got stuck it's the
other hand you just go to the other hand
don't don't Yes.
But what happened is she shifted her she
changed your contact point on your right
hand with her left hand and then it
captured your mind and then you
contested on that new contact point that
she regained her leverage on and then
you had to be told the other hand is
available. Okay. So you don't want to be
trapped like that.
That's what we mean by release. I don't
get trapped.
Your feet too don't have to get trapped.
The stink yin and yong hand from the
beginning. Try it again.
Go around it. Go around it. No. Go
around it. Don't Don't Don't try to do
something to it.
See how you see how you pull you pulling
that hand. Did you feel that pull? Okay.
So, the other thing you can do is with
your body. Okay. So, you're you got here
like that and then pulling that out. Do
you see that? Okay. So, the reason that
you're pulling that out is because it's
relationship to your center. My center
is on the is on the other side and the
active qua
can't get to push on there. So, you can
get it to where you want it to be. And
look how I shifted weight. Do you see
that? Okay. And now my body's not
pulling it on the outer deltoid.
>> So, you're you're over here and you're
trying to pull it across. Yeah, you
can't move the other side and then you
rotate the qua
and it goes
yin again. Okay, so the hands are yin
and yang to each other. The hand is yin
and yang to each other and the hand is
the arms are yin and yang to what my qua
and center is doing. Okay.
>> Okay.
It's too much to remember that and I
that's why you just find the feeling and
the release.
>> So you had a yin yield and then the
spine is available.
I know it feels like I'm beating the
crap out of you when I go to your spine,
but if you watch the video, it's just
slow. It's just that's how much the
direct control is because we now have
more uh we've bridged more towards
close-range grappling with the
internals. Do you get that? So, when you
watch the video, you're going to be
shocked at how slow I'm actually moving.
Okay? It just feels like it. So, don't
you're not going to kill her. You don't
have to kill her. It didn't I'm was
going very slow.
If it happens again,
go around things. So there's that right
hand. Do you see?
>> You got it. You can step and get your
center. No, I would get my center on the
other side of that hand. I would go
forward and turn. Left foot. Forward.
Left foot. There it is. Right there. Do
you see? Yes. Got it.
We should note your instinct there. Pull
her across even harder. Okay. So, there
it is again. Yep. There it is again.
Good. Yep.
Change hands distinctly.
Point your fingers down on the right.
Shift. There it is. Right there.
Change hands distinctly.
That would be the one where you shift
you can shift your weight and you get
more yong out of your left hand
>> without clashing.
Left hand push. Then get ready to shift
your weight more and rotate. Don't take
don't change your feet. You're just
going to shift and rotate onto your left
foot.
when she crosses. Yep. Start turning
your claw. There you go.
Point your fingers down and make that
hand, left hand go down. Left hand
straight down. Shift your weight to the
right foot. Rotate around that. Yep.
Keep turning more. Turn. Turn. Turn.
You're you're you're
going to do
this.
>> Okay. You keep leaving that foot there.
Okay. You're going to turn on the ball
of the foot and the quad will turn here.
Okay. Try it again.
It's just like shodang.
Shift and turn. Shift and turn. Turn to
the right. Turn to the right. Turn to
the right. Better.
It's probably because you're you're
bracing by squatting back. Your line of
gravity is in between your two feet and
that's why you can't do that turn so
easily. Okay.
Point your extend your arm down. Shift
to the right. Turn to the left.
That's it. And then keep extending the
hand down.
Okay. Uh this is just for this drill.
It's not important, but Marshi, you want
to always think about that. Um let's say
she's in that in this stance. Do you see
she's in Ihan me? Uh if you take her to
this to this way, she'll always be able
to step into that. Do you see? If you
take her the other way, then you get her
outside that edge. She has that
awkwardness. Okay? Do do you understand?
So, I think you're just kind of picking
what's comfortable for you regardless of
what her feet are doing. So, sometimes
she's coming in and I me and sometimes
she's coming in in gaku me and you're
like, I just I just like this way. Well,
she's always going to take that step and
you're not any closer to getting her off
balance. Do you see? Or whereas if you
go this way, you're much closer to
getting her off balance. Okay. All
right. So, just be cognitive of that
difference. It plays a role marshally.
Okay. energetically irrelevant
but the favoritism spiritually is very
relevant. We don't have a favorite.
I don't I don't know why you're trying
to hook her. If she's pulling on you,
then I don't need to hook her. Do you do
you understand that you need to not hook
her?
Shift your weight.
So, here's it's I tried to get myself in
stupid situations. Okay. But when you're
when you're here like that, I don't want
to go back towards your hook.
>> Okay.
>> So, let's put that foot there. Okay.
That way the camera can see it. So, I
don't want to come against your hook.
>> So, when you go to pull, right, you go
to pull. Do you understand? Okay. Let's
start over. Okay. All right. So, she
goes to pull, then I'll go here.
>> Hi.
>> You see? Hi. And I don't try to pull
that back.
>> I'll go. You go there. I go there. Then
this one takes over. Okay. Do you
understand?
>> Okay. You keep trying to hook and then
the arm's not getting low enough
>> for what you're trying to do.
>> Okay. You're keeping your arm up.
If he can't go lower, that means the
other hand can turn around. push the
other hand and as it gets tight, you
lower the right hand. Do you understand?
So that's where I would have grabbed
your head, Virginia, cuz you did a yin
yield when you changed your grip. Just
so you know what you're doing. Okay.
Turn it. Turn it.
Yep.
Good. It's fine. We're here. But you
know what's going to happen, right? When
you keep turning it to your left,
bouching, what's going to happen?
>> Yes. Okay. Which is fine. You got here.
Doesn't matter. But you could see what I
was talking about. There we are. Okay.
Don't contest the initial thing.
So, this isn't this is we're not going
to be able to rotate.
Okay. So, uh going to have to free your
mind a little. Okay. So, this is what
remember the last thing I said was I try
to get in weird positions. Okay. All
right. So, if in other words, you guys
know uh if you push, right? Do you
understand? Uh,
I will get myself like you're driving
really hard. Okay. Then I'll get like
here. Do you see?
>> And I'll do it.
>> But I don't I don't have to do that.
Okay.
It doesn't even look like she was
pushing. Do you? Okay. So likewise,
okay, when when she goes to grab,
it doesn't look like she was pulling
either. Do you Do you understand? Okay.
So now you would go why why
>> you're not contesting.
>> Yeah. Cuz the all the energy is being
internalized. So there's really no you
can't get in awkward positions. That's
why you do this. Okay. Do you got it? So
what is happening here now is you're
uh you're getting in an awkward position
not by conscious choice like me. So,
it's probably you're watching me and
you're like thinking that was okay, but
I I'm not in any threat because go
because you pulled me to here. Do you
get that? I I am in the same grounding.
So, if she pushes from here, I'm in the
same thing. She pulls from here, I'm in
the same thing. Do you understand?
Whereas
when you getting pulled, you're like I
could see the tension and you're like
you got you're in the shoulders, your
foots off the ground, you're nowhere
near able to do anything. Okay? So the
advice I'm going to give you is as soon
as they touch, you're already
trying to find that same connection.
>> Hi.
>> Okay. Okay. You're getting too deep into
an incorrect move. It's too hard to come
out of there for where you're at right
now. Okay? So,
free this a little bit
right away. Go to yinyang.
Follow the rules.
Fine. Yep. Yep. Lower. Cut down. Yes.
If one hand can't go up, the other hand
can go down. One hand can't go in, the
other hand can go out.
If neither hand can do anything, I move
my center.
Make sure they're doing different
things.
And you need more range. You step and
you turn your center.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Lower. Lower. Lower.
Good. around. Good.
Oh, if we're just going to keep
stepping, stepping, stepping, we should
have done that on the first one. You're
not ready. Get ready. Go. Go.
Lower around.
Tilt. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope.
You're going to do something with your
arms right at touch.
>> Internalize. Change to yinyang.
Nope. Nope. Nope. You're stepping to get
out of it, not stepping to continue
something.
Yin yang. Get your hands off the table.
Start over. Change heights. Split them
apart. Teni.
Point down. One hand goes up and around.
They don't both don't lower.
>> Do something. Ti
shift weight.
Switch rolls. Same thing. I don't want
you getting suckered at the beginning.
Do something.
Good. Good.
Good. Always look to spiral rotate.
Don't Don't trust the linear lines.
Get off that ledge. Unless you're going
to just hold it in place and go around
it. Do you understand? Don't push the
ledge down anymore.
There. Ledge stays. Enter and turn.
Enter. Turn. Good. You can always shift
your weight
and you go further down the roller
coaster line. No, it's always going to
be better to intern turn there because
your your center is on the east side of
it. So when you go backwards on someone
that's pulling, you're going to clash.
But if she's pulling and you enter west
of it, then you will be able to go with
her energy. Okay? Which you should have
felt the increase in yong and you don't
do it.
>> Good. So you step around her pull. There
it is. Shift your weight to the right
foot. Do you understand?
>> Yeah.
Step, turn, shift.
She's pulling. Good.
Shift.
More weight. Shifting. So, I know you're
not pinning yourself by being double
weighted.
Yeah.
And we don't have to be so Yosh con
fluid.
You can try to get your foot down.
It's going to be a little harder because
we're not letting you get so deep into
your advantage, but you should still
try. Yes. And now you'll see the reason
for the weight shift. Okay.
Yes.
One more rotation. Uh bouching you go.
Bouching you go. Get early. Oh, try it
again. So, so don't you control the
pace. Do not stick your hands out there
until you are on the front foot.
>> Get the heaven and earth hands.
All right. So, let me help this. I I
don't I gave you everything you need,
okay? But not enough. Okay. So, you have
you have these elements, okay? So pay
attention.
>> You have uh a fire in
>> you have water out.
>> You'll have heaven up.
>> Hi.
>> You'll have earth down.
So to go max yang, you'd be what? Where
you think?
>> Uh heaven and up.
>> Heaven and right. Up and in. Up and in.
You got it.
>> Then out and down.
>> Okay. Got it. So you keep being on the
table.
>> Okay.
>> So that's what I mean. Tensi or it's
heaven and earth. You see?
>> Okay. And now when she tries to shuffle
on this, that's where you are basically
doing the X pattern. Okay. Doesn't
matter. Boom.
Now it doesn't
Now it doesn't look like she's doing
anything other than coming in and
holding. Although we all know she's
pulling and trying to get her foot down.
Okay.
>> All right.
manifest
yin and yang.
Now move your move your feet if you need
to.
I would move the other foot to get on
the other side of her pull. There it is.
Enter. Shift your weight. Shift your
weight just like I told her.
Keep the earth hand going. Yes. Good.
Don't let the earth hand up or they will
always step out of it like that. The
earth hand must continue to lower. Shift
your weight. Yes.
You have to keep that foot compromised.
That's what the earth hand is doing. You
know she's going to get that step. Keep
the foot compromised with the earth
hand. Shift. Good. Don't fall off the
cliff either. That doesn't make sense.
Right away. No. Too small.
>> Yin yang. Good. Shift. Rotate. Shift.
Good. Okay. All right. Good. Pull up
something.